according to President Trump you need a
picture ID to buy groceries any any
reason I guess to justify using voter ID
laws to suppress voters that's what the
President of the United States is doing
in a rally yesterday in Florida this is
what the President of the United States
had to say which is why the time has
come for voter ID like everything else
voter ID you know if you go out and you
want to buy groceries you need a picture
on a card you need ID you go out and you
want to buy anything you need ID and you
need your picture now earlier in today's
show we talked about the disconnect with
reality that Donald Trump supporters
have right and clearly this is another
example of it because in what world do
you have to go out and use an ID to buy
it the absurdity of it is is pointless
pointing it out right there's like I
said there's very little utility in
pointing out how ridiculous
conservatives have gotten but the real
purpose of this is to make the
assumption that our to make the claim
that needing a voter ID to vote is as
commonplace as going to the grocery
store when it's not the underlying
premise of voter ID laws really is voter
suppression let's just be clear about
that I want to bring up a quote here to
put it in context voting rights and this
is according to the hill voting rights
groups have challenged a series of state
voter ID laws arguing that they are
intended to suppress voter turnout among
minority populations well Republicans
have fought for stronger voter ID law
saying that they are necessary to
prevent voter fraud now we know that
second part is completely untrue Mike
ters I from a Republican leader of the
Republican Party of Pennsylvania made
that clear all the way back in 2012 when
he inadvertently let the world know
exactly why they instituted voter ID
laws voter ID which is gonna allow
Governor Ron
to win the state of Pennsylvania done I
mean don't take my word for it from his
own mouth the whole purpose of voter ID
laws is to help the Republican Party win
and maintain political power that's what
it has always been the Brennan Center
has done extensive research in it in
this and you should look at their work
but I want to summarize their work with
three statements from their website this
is what they say studies agree
impersonation fraud by voters very
rarely happens courts agree fraud by
voters at the polls is nearly
non-existent government investigations
agree voter fraud is rare yet the
President of the United States and the
Republican Party relentlessly attempt to
into Institute voter ID laws across the
country voter ID laws have a direct
effect on minority populations
participating in voting that has been
documented whether or not it has the
ability to turn an election has yet to
be determined but we do know that it
affects minority participation in voting
and Republicans know that when
minorities vote they generally vote for
the Democratic Party I wonder why that
is take a look at your policies perhaps
but instead of changing their policies
instead of doing anything to ameliorate
the type of racism that exists both
against black people and brown people
with immigration policy instead of
changing any of that they say hmm the
solution here is to well since
minorities don't like how racist we are
let's just make sure minorities can't
vote and the way you do that is making
voter ID as ridiculous as I don't know
going to the grocery store and having to
show ID and in that conflated statement
that makes absolutely no sense is
exactly where the Republican Party
exists that's where they're thinking
rest and that is how they are going to
get this pass across the country if we
don't do something about it that's all
the time we have for today
thanks to Pat over at the studio thanks
to max over at the studio David it will
be back tomorrow david thanks for having
me and hopefully I'll see you all again
take care